well hello reject nation it's correct
yeah man is John over here I was at the
gym the second I got to the gym oh my
gosh did the rampage trailer drop but I
must work out to be like Dwayne the rock
Johnson yeah five chickens a day need
five chicken live chicken lunch a day
feathers fiber and then I wait for the
eggs to hash and then I eat those mm-hmm
in a glass raw like Ron yeah just a
bunch of hey guys
rampage trailer I'm really hoping for is
that business trailer before the trailer
because I might just stop it how will I
know if I want to watch the trailer
that's true and picture of the day shad
are gonna go out some new fellow
patronage act David Gandy thanks for
joining our patreon shout out after the
review no character would you watch
[Music]
exactly what you watch
[Music]
George of seven feet weighed 500 pounds
Oh
what's happening to my friends
[Music]
so mainly I was
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
The Mummy playing cry yeah
[Music]
of course it's a helicopter pilot again
oh my goodness
we're gonna put them down down
[Music]
my god Godzilla I think I name five
movies yeah
wait there's more oh that was the
trailer go back is there is cables hand
hey listen I am in no way shape or form
saying this movie looks exactly like a
good movie but that looks like a total
fun whether it be cheesy and bad or good
intentionally cheesy either way I think
I'm gonna walk out of this movie going
that looks like a really fun time yeah
I'm kind of with you there I don't know
if this necessarily looks like a good
movie to me because by now I mean this
is that character I'm used to seeing the
rock plays that rock movie the first 30
seconds looked like exactly from the
trailer of Jumanji yeah well and I'm I
am not surprised this is from the
director of San Andreas because it looks
like saying it's the first image I saw
yesterday when they were like oh the
rampage like rampage is coming I was
like that reminds me of San Andreas I
almost feel like he could be the same
character just you know a few years
later and something tells me there might
be a little more comedy infused than
than in Syria straight cuz this is a
serious tonal trailer even gets
implanted Rise of the Planet asipi Rim
Jumanji Sanna Sanna is roland emmerich
film Rise of the Planet of the Apes
there's so many different films I really
expect me to take this seriously it's
one of the rock is best friends with a
damn gorilla even though it was way too
big he's like
[Music]
he's huge and their other huge monsters
and they're clearly all destroyed yeah
like I am all for friendship man but I
think you're gonna have to rethink this
one one a good benefit I think to it is
that there is this because you know all
I remember from the arcade of the
rampage game is the giant gorilla smash
in the cities the fact that they are
actually giving the gorillas a character
instead of it let's just make it about
only the rock but now it's about the
rock
it's James Franco and Caesar and the
play you're putting a human character at
the center of this and I'm at a point
now where I don't know if that's
actually gonna help anything like the
original rampage you just pick a monster
and destroy at least they have the
character be the gorilla character being
his strong relation to they could have
just been a villainous character yeah
cuz the rock doesn't get along with
people yeah this one gorilla and Jeffrey
Dean Morgan Joe and Joe mainly on Oh or
Manganiello man Joe Joe jell-o shot that
movie looks really fun I feel like this
is overall gonna be a bad movie but an
entertaining time at the end of the day
that's all I care about is that it's
entertained a different movie this looks
like transformers with the rock and
they're just monsters instead yeah or
Kong Skull Island in Chicago paid a
shout out for David Gandy today David
Gandy is one of our older patrons over
the age of 50 and I was messaging him
and patreon and he was telling me how a
couple years ago he actually discovered
our channel told man and he was
diagnosed with cancer and over the
course of a couple years is going
through chemotherapy and all this
treatment he was able to beat the cancer
and he said he was watching our Channel
the whole time and that it really helped
him get through really tough times so
David Gandy that really touched my heart
laughter and with that David up I just
want to say can you smell what The Rock
is cooking cancer cells but if anybody
could save you from that it is the rock
it is the rubber there will be a movie
in the future Roxy
the cure thanks for being part of our
patron David you can subscribe to the
real rejects please click that
notification about to get notified every
time one of our videos is out follow us
on social media we're on the stardust
app right now and that app allows you to
do 30-second reactions for any film TV
show or trailer we use as a catch up on
a lot of things that might not even go
up on YouTube so follow us there
take care people